MORE CRIMINAL MIGRANTS WERE
APPREHENDED TRYING TO ENTER,
INCLUDING A CONVICTED.
>> Dana: AS IF THE CRISIS AT
THE BORDER WASN'T STRONG ENOUGH,
RASHIDA TLAIB WANTS TO TAKE AWAY
RESOURCES.
YES, SHE IS CALLING TO DEFINE
THE KEY AGENCIES AT THE BORDER
THAT STEM THE FLOW OF PEOPLE
TRYING TO ENTER THE U.S.
ILLEGALLY.
>> WE MUST ELIMINATE FINDING.
THESE AGENCIES -- HE MAY MAKES
THEY ARE IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
INSTEAD, THEY TERRORIZED MIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
SPEECH IS TOM COTTON SERVES ON
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO ONE
OTHER BIT OF SAND FROM THE
CONGRESSWOMAN BECAUSE SHE IS
TRYING TO SAY THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON
CAN'T AGREE WITH HER.
WATCH.
THINK OF ANY MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
ARE COMING FULL FORCE AND
PUSHING BACK AGAINST THIS IDEA
AROUND -- THEY RENAMED THIS KIND
OF MILITARIZATION OR TARGETING
IN A VERY INHUMANE WAY OF OUR
IMMIGRANTS NEIGHBORS.
IT IS THE SAME THING WHICH IS
TARGETING COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IN A WAY THAT IS, TO ME, VERY
MUCH VIOLATES HUMAN RIGHTS.
>> Dana: LET'S GET YOUR TAKE
ON THIS, SENATOR.
>> I THINK SHE IS RIGHT.
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS TO SUPPORT
THOSE RADICAL VIEWS.
THEY WANT TO DEFUND THE POLICE
AND TURNED AMERICA INTO A
SANCTUARY COUNTRY ARE ALL
ILLEGAL ALIENS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD.
THAT LOGIC IS BEING EXTENDED TO
OUR BORDER PATROL AND
IMMIGRATIONS AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT.
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO ME IF
RASHIDA TLAIB WOULD EXPLAIN
EXACTLY WHO SHE THINKS SHOULD BE
EXCLUDED FROM OUR COUNTRY WHEN
THEY SHOW UP AT OUR BORDER,
IRRESPECTIVE OF OUR LAWS.
OR WHO IN AMERICA SHOULD BE
DEPORTED.
MAYBE SHE WOULD TAKE
CONSERVATIVES OR REPUBLICANS OR
ANYONE WHO VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
IT SEEMS LIKE BEYOND THAT, SHE
BELIEVES THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
TOTALLY OPEN BORDERS AND ANYONE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO COME TO THE
COUNTRY.
THAT IS A RECIPE FOR DISASTER.
>> Dana: SOME OTHER OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES SENT A LETTER TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, MERRICK
GARLAND.
HERE IS MARK BROWN OF EDGE, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF ARIZONA.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
SITUATION AT THE BORDER AS HE
SEES IT.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION IS MAKING
A CHOICE BETWEEN MIGRANTS AND
AMERICANS, THEY ARE TELLING THE
WRONG PEOPLE TO STAY HOME.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SHUT DOWN OUR
ECONOMY.
THE BIGGEST HEALTH CRISIS FACING
OUR COUNTRY TODAY IS A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
WE MAY HAVE THREE VACCINES FOR
COVID, BUT THERE IS NO CARE FOR
US TO BED.
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
EXPLAIN STUPID.
SPT DO YOU THINK THEY WILL
ENABLE IT TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
ATTENTION FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL?
SPEAK AT THE CRISIS IS GOING TO
GET WORSE.
FIRST HE PROMISED OPEN BORDERS
FROM THE CAMPAIGN.
THEY HEARD IT.
I SPOKE TO SEVERAL AT THE BORDER
AND THEY ALL GAVE SOME ANSWER
LIKE JOE BIDEN.
SECOND, HE REVERSED A LOT OF
EFFECTIVE POLICIES, MOST NOTABLY
THE REMAINING MEXICO POLICY
WHICH REQUIRED MIGRANTS SEEKING
ASYLUM TO STAY IN MEXICO.
NOW WE ARE ABOUT TO HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE THE DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO PURSUE AMNESTY AND
DATA COMING BUDGET BILL.
THIS IS THE WORD WE HAVE BEEN
GETTING OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
THEY WANT TO INCLUDE A MASSIVE
AMNESTY NOT LEGISLATION.
THAT WILL ACT AS A BIGGER MAGNET
FOR MORE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
>> Dana: IS NOT SOMETHING THEY
WANT TO DO UNDER THE
RECONCILIATION BILL?
>> THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
THEY KNOW THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
NEVER GOING TO SUPPORT SOME KIND
OF MASSIVE AMNESTY, CERTAINLY
WITH OUR BORDER TOTALLY OPEN.
BERNIE SANDERS, CHUCK SCHUMER,
NANCY PELOSI, AND JOE BIDEN'S
ADMINISTRATION ARE ACTIVELY
WORKING BEHIND CLOSED DOORS TO
TRY TO INCLUDE IN AMNESTY AND AD
BUDGET BILL.
THAT IS SOMETHING I AM GOING TO
FIGHT TO THE BETTER AND TO STOP
BECAUSE WE DO NOT NEED A SINGLE
NEW ILLEGAL ALIEN COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY AND WE ARE ALREADY AT A
GENERATIONAL HIGH LEVEL.
>> Dana: AS THEY CAN DO THAT
ON RECONCILIATION, THAT WILL GET
A LOT OF ATTENTION.
ONE LAST THING.
THERE ARE A BUNCH OF
PROGRESSIVES THAT ARE SENDING A
LETTER TO THE ADMINISTRATION
WARNING THEM NOT TO BE TOUGH ON
CHINA BECAUSE THAT COULD HURT
THE FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE, AS IF CHINA WAS
PARTICIPATING IN TRYING TO HELP
US IN THAT REGARD ANYWAY.
>> [LAUGHS]
THAT LETTER SOUNDS LIKE CHINESE
PROPAGANDA.
THE CHINESE EVEN HAVE A WORD FOR
THIS.
IT TRANSLATES LOOSELY TO "WHITE
LIBERAL."
PEOPLE WHO ARE ONLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THINGS LIKE IMMIGRATION
AND THE ENVIRONMENT AND WHO ARE
WILLING TO SACRIFICE AMERICAN
JOBS AND PROSPERITY.
WILLING TO LOOK THE OTHER WAY IN
TERMS OF WHEN IT COMES TO -- IT
IS TIME TO LOWER THE BOOM ON THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY AND NOT
TO LOOK THE OTHER WAY IN HOPES
OF CLIMATE CHANGE PROMISES THAT
ARE NEVER GOING TO COME T